c'est au pas de tir yann habile à qui
elle m'appelait un laminak jan map et à
la villette appel patois mais s'est fait
livrer plaindre j'ai vu rémy safar aux
son mec me direz il se fait 1500 qui
aujourd'hui semble acquis il est
formidable ce n'était pas une option
mais pourquoi l ap hp un magasin le mari
ouais la barre est interflora xi fait
chier maria leur nabil a essayé de
m'appeler aujourd'hui marche des ratés à
cause de toi ma belle longueur alors
c'est la villa nabil uche mon coeur dame
je voulais te dire bon anniversaire tu
sais que je t'aime ma chérie et j'ai ton
cadeau donc lecture via paris je te le
donne t'embrasse mon thomas d'amour
aussi et tout les voilà dans l'enfant
quoi avec un grand l je sais qu abbas et
le principe de l'anniversaire c'est un
an de plus mais tu es toujours aussi
formidable mais aussi ben tu sais que je
t'aime
nabila c'est que te lâcherai jamais ma
chérie magré secte a aussi ses thèmes
forts chérie je t'aime fort je
t'embrasse et bon anniversaire et tu
viens boire chez de faire une grosse
fête et 1000 personnes 4000 watts de son
[Musique]
au thème à chéri d'amour je t'embrasse
chéri salut mon coeur je suis resté choc
à dos le cas oui mais un double bogey